good morning hey guys nice to see you
guys again we are on our way to Las
Vegas with the entire JK crew so it was
like a family bonding trip even though
we just came back from Japan not too
long ago but that's how awesome JK is
that we love family bonding trips so
right now we're on our way to the office
we're going to pick up Devin and Lauren
and if you guys don't know who they are
they're actually our JK news editors so
we're gonna actually take this road trip
to Vegas with them and if you guys
notice I'm talking really weird I
actually started using some clear
aligners which I've told you guys and my
snapchat before follow me on snapchat I
tell you guys everything there but
anyways every time we go travel KC is
never really happy are you baby he's
always so stressed you think about all
the stuff that we have to do and all the
stuff that needs to be done and all the
stuff that you need to do this is this
is the KC that I deal with to be trouble
so like this then it's okay you'll get
happy with you're there right yeah I
guess so I'm not a big biggest person
but you really am NOT a biggest person I
mean I'm not really a biggest person
either but it's just not even about
Vegas it's just about us having fun
you can't even get excited about that
hello good morning Lauren look at you
you're already gave us a magic party and
who's over here hello everyone tips you
like you like my patchy legs right now
what do you mean patchy all the like
little like random patches of hair I
think we can even see on camera bull
guys I got here on time today that is a
freaking miracle so we actually told
Devan all right dude we're meeting at
the office at 10:00 a.m. you cannot be
late but in reality we're meeting at
11:00 I lied to him cuz he's forever
late forever late oh yeah I ended up
telling him this morning just kidding
we're meeting at 11:00 but you better
not be late cuz we're gonna leave you
and else this morning it was actually a
fun time we were actually late long as
we got here at 11:30 but I think it's
forgiven we're the ones driving so it's
okay what so excited Vegas time come on
get very excited I'm just I don't know
I'm just not a Vegas person stop saying
that just be a a boyfriend
it's a birthday at the subway and get
some gas and since we're at the gas
station we're gonna stock up on some
goodies but Lauren would you bring
already I brought pineapple all the way
from Disneyland Oh yummy I love to see
lamp at home cheese puffs from shitty
job oh girl nice doing anything Devin
did you contribute I've got a broad
muscle for entertainment Corian I
brought this fresh like a suit what do
you think of the suit
it's very very very purple just like my
hair yeah there you'll to be that glove
purple Perkin perky perky
that purple purple yeah hey that's
racist may think what a great drink is
good all right I'm gonna see in these
plots he's a really cool kid all right
buy some goodies so you're all the
snacks I kind of went a little candy
crazy and water and some red Bull we're
prepared now
yeah did you get me chocolate it yeah
and ask for anything Devon you're
supposed to know how today I don't know
you
all right here family in Vegas and we
are at the Nobu hotel that's how you
cook news and that's as black as Devin
gets
actually unlike any other Vegas hotel
I've ever been asked because twisties
was check-in right here
so most Vegas hotels have like really
grand like check-in counters it's much
more intimate kind of like it
you're not like around a whole bunch of
all the other people with smoked
cigarette and drunk people all right we
are in our hotel suite
Curtis you're checking we have a
king-sized bed that is inspired is it
asian-inspired
yeah who says it's attraction that's
what Joe and I said that this hotels
asian-inspired
honestly it looks like a strand of pubes
oh yeah no busan super japanese actually
you're right and all this stuff super
Japan look Hank I don't know have to
really pee Raven II do people love you
but we should go show the factor your
little hop you see I told you I told you
you're gonna get excited once we're here
this place is nice Luis it's all bamboo
when you baby baby like a three-year-old
or four or five years is like dude I can
fit in there that thing is huge oh the
steam room the shower oh there's a seat
Oh cute because usually these kinds of
bathrooms are like super super sealed
like that and especially in these fancy
hotels they're usually steamer
really you want me to vlog you pain
which is really neither okay bye hey
yeah it's a happy way I hate if we hate
your kissing feet all right we got
ourselves situated we are now gonna go
visit the Mafia
whoa whoa and over there and a bidet
Japanese theme or did we get a bidet I
even check your feet on it oh we don't
know how oh you guys have doubled down
time oh my god who's that who's that
so now we will be going to dinner with
the entire crew who are here today on
Friday because the rest of the people
are coming later tonight or tomorrow so
I thought you know what we're in Vegas
let me dress up a little bit now just
the Amish for the movies not the jewelry
this is the horses we ordered this is my
hand
oh my god
took my wallet from my pocket grabbed
the money out and gave me tiny oysters
$23
this one looks really good though
is skewered Chilean seabass my favorite
fishes in the world
two and two
on my channel
vultures
it used to me
one thing but taste is another
that's the ginger relish better my
better my ginger relish
good morning so last night was a trip so
as far as I could figure out some guy
was strong we just finished playing pool
at the suite we got back to our room and
we were getting ready to go to bed and
all of a sudden you just hear like this
screeching noise and all like what the
hell like what's going on so we're both
trying to figure out with the noise one
but then sometimes like there was
moments where the screeching would
actually have like a kind of yeah we
thought we thought it was just people
having very violent sex so we're like oh
my gosh it was going on so then next
thing you know I look out the window and
I see a silhouette of a dude and I'm
like oh my god maybe there's somebody
inside the window and I was like like
not prepared for anyone else to see
these oh my god so then um you know
there is dude and like he's just
screaming and yelling and like we're
just ripping out like what's going on
luckily we had like the sheer curtain
yeah the sheer curtains so that kind of
like protected us so immediately that
someone can see turned off the lights
when that guy couldn't see us inside and
then I tell Casey I'm like grab the
camera crabs again we're grabbing the
camera just grab the camera and then
like that's pretty much what we got I
was almost scared because I thought I
was gonna jump and I knew really yeah I
felt like yeah I didn't realize how high
up we were
wondering how is he even able to go
outside because if he has the same room
that we have there's no way you can get
out of this window that's your great
game we don't know what ended up
happening we don't know security ended
up showing up because when KC was still
on the phone with with security this
dude just took off that way so we don't
even know what happened in the end but
right now we're running late we have to
go eat meet up with everybody is in the
afternoon it's lunch time we're gonna go
eat at some Gordon Ramsay restaurants
I'm hungry let's go
what are Ramsay I would love for him to
yell at me one day